within Legend the expanded universe that
sprung forth after George Lucas's first
six Star Wars movies orange lightsabers
are most often used by gray Jedi they
are not fully members of the Jedi Order
utilizing both the light and dark sides
of the force we are no Jedi
in these instances orange lightsabers
represent their middle ground with
orange being a cross between red
lightsabers used by The Sith and yellow
Savers used by guards of the Jedi Temple
it's also worth noting that the video
game Knights of the Old Republic 2
suggests that Darth Revan may have used
an orange lightsaber after his
Redemption and that's a character with
more than a little experience walking
the line between light and dark that
said several full-fledged members of the
Jedi Order used orange lightsabers too
for instance yaddle wielded an orange
blade in Legends before it was replaced
with a standard greenblade for Tales of
the Jedi additionally placoon used an
orange lightsaber in Legends although
he's been depicted using different
colors in various other media foreign